i'm so glad to introduce you to makeup
instagram god it's me and chad
hey everyone my name is nian i'm a video
director based in brooklyn new york
and i am back to do a little tutorial
for you today and a couple of other
tutorials throughout the summer so you
will see me
again sorry so today we are going to
guasa wasa is a very ancient chinese
practice that essentially involves what
is on your face scraping
the face to drain lymph improve
circulation
improve tone give yourself a radiant
kind of complexion i personally
love it when i wake up and i'm feeling
puffy
and i want to just just get everything
moving what you'll need is a gwasa tool
this one
was made by my good friend sandra
lanchin she has a spa here in
williamsburg and she's actually the
woman who taught me
how to guasa she's an amazing youtube
video that's going to be much longer
than this if you guys want to check it
out and learn it more about the process
because i'm definitely not
an expert in gwasa but i do it all the
time and i love it you'll also need
a facial oil this one is by biosance and
it's an amazing lightweight oil
and then you might need supplementary
facial spray just to keep things
moving the important thing here is
you're going to be giving yourself a
facial massage essentially
so you want to make sure that there's
always something there
so that the gua saw tool isn't pulling
or dragging on the skin in an aggressive
way starting off with
clean freshly cleaned towel dried skin
i'm going to take a little bit of this
facial oil
and apply that all over my face
also going to my hair up
some really basic wasa technique is that
you should always be
gliding your tulle in on a
flat in a flat way so you're not using
the edge of your tool like this
you're really pulling and scraping
using the flat edges of your tool as
opposed to
the side so i like to start with my
jawline that's where i feel that i get a
lot of
puffiness i also have tmj so because i
have tmj my jaw gets very tight
and this is how it really helps with
massaging so i usually take my tool
i'll use it on the side and i'll scrape
from the chin
up to the end of my jaw
give it a little wiggle to give yourself
a little massage and then i like to pull
down and later i'll pull back up
you can kind of rest your other hand on
your chin if you want to kind of
assist in the pull
[Music]
it feels amazing guys so i typically do
this for
five minutes at a time but if you go to
like at a real
facial like where it's professionally
done and i highly suggest you do it i
fall asleep every time they'll do it for
10 20 minutes and you just get you see a
huge difference so actually actually you
know what i'm gonna do i'm going to
only do one side of my face and see if
you can see a difference
[Music]
then i can move on to my cheekbone area
same scraping motion wiggling at the
side when you're done
if you feel that the oil is starting to
absorb
and you're getting a little bit less
slip and you don't want to apply
more oil because you think it's gonna be
too heavy that's where your facial spray
can come in
just to get get things
wet and moving again because again you
really don't want to be dragging or
pulling at your skin
i'm really just carving out my cheekbone
here the effects that you're going to
get from guasa
while i do think it's great to do it
regularly
it's not going to be like you do one
time and you have a lifted face forever
now we can move on to the under eye area
give that a little bit of lift
get that fluid moving it can help
honestly with if you have some
discoloration
under there what i like to do is i'll
put my finger here
as an anchor point take one of the sides
of your tool
and same thing you're scraping on with
the flat edge
up to your temple
now we can move on to the eyebrow area
where you can get a little bit of a
lifted effect so you take the kind of
butterfly
kind of area of your tool which by the
way you can find
these tools you can get them at sephora
you can buy them from
treatment by lunch lantern like i did
lots of places sell them
and they're great and they're a great
investment they're not that expensive
and you have them forever as long as you
don't
don't drop it because they do they will
break so take
the butterfly end of your tool you're
just going to scrape
over your brow bone and then lift up
give it a little wiggle again be very
very gentle around your eye another
thing you can do
in this area to kind of lift the brow
bone is take
the side of your tool like this and you
scrape
up basically pull your eyebrow up this
also feels really good because even
muscle there
feels like a little massage and then
we're gonna move on to your side face
but something you can do in the center
but that is my
second favorite move beyond the jawline
is take the butterfly sections you're
going to massage
this area of your face people tend to
furrow it a lot
if you get a headache sometimes you feel
it there and it feels so good to start
here
give the little wig a little massage
pull up
wiggle again i mean i feel like i can
see a difference
in the lifting of this side of my jaw
we'll do the other side now
voila you can also use this tool in
other ways you can use it
to give yourself a shoulder massage like
this same way you can go in the back of
your
neck and kind of scrape up and that also
feels very good but it's a very handy
really useful tool i love having it
it feels so good to do
highly recommend so let me know if you
guys try it
it is a really lovely practice i highly
suggest that you guys
you know take this video as a little bit
of a primer but definitely check out
sandra's video which is
much more in depth and learn more about
the history of the practice too so
see you guys next time bye
you